Bonjour à tous!
Dans l'épisode 9 de Chroniques de Prof, que
vous retrouverez dans la description, nous
avions commencé à faire l'histoire de la
piraterie.
-On avait commencé par parler de la piraterie
dans l'Antiquité, puis au Moyen-Âge (FTW),
ce qui nous laisse la piraterie à l'époque
moderne et on va même un peu pousser vers
l'époque contemporaine!
-Ne mettons pas la charrue avant les bœufs!
Vous avez dit époque moderne, ça veut dire
que je vais pouvoir parler cette fois?
-Moui, t'as l'air d'avoir le look qu'il faut.
-ENFIN!
-En avant donc pour cette deuxième partie
de Chroniques de Prof sur la piraterie!
Dans cette partie nous allons nous intéresser
principalement à la mer des Caraïbes et
à la mer de Chine.
On parle d'âge d'or de la piraterie entre
les années 1520 et 1720, la piraterie étant
la plus importante au XVIIe siècle.
En quoi consiste-t-elle exactement? Eh bien...
-On mène des attaques éclair sur des navires,
pour prendre tout ce qu'on peut trouver et
repartir aussi vite! Pour ça, parfois on
fait croire au navire visé qu'on est de pauvres
marchands en détresse! On les laisse s'approcher
et BIM, on s'amarre à leur bateau et à ce
moment là, ils sont déjà dans la mouise.
-Parfois les pirates s'attaquent également
à des villes côtières d'Amérique du Sud.
Pour cela, il leur arrive même de rassembler
plusieurs navires qui s'allient le temps d'une
attaque.
On connaît les pirates des Caraïbes à travers
de nombreux stéréotypes véhiculés à partir
du XIXe siècle, avec l'île au trésor de
Stevenson par exemple, ou l'attraction pirates
des Caraïbes de Disneyland.
On s'imagine des pirates saoulés au rhum,
borgnes, avec un perroquet sur l'épaule,
un crochet en guise de main...
-Alors que je suis quelqu'un de tout à fait
normal!
-T'est sûre de ce que tu dis?
Concernant ces idées reçues, je vais m'attarder
sur le drapeau pirate qui n'apparaît en fait
qu'au XVIIIe siècle, soit à la fin de l'âge
d'or de la piraterie.
Il s'agit en fait d'un pavillon, puisque c'est
ainsi qu'on appelle les drapeaux maritimes,
et son petit nom est le Jolly Roger.
Le thème de la tête de mort et des tibias
ou sabres qu'on retrouve sur la plupart de
ces pavillons appartient au genre artistique
du Memento Mori, employé depuis l'Antiquité,
soit «souviens-toi que tu vas mourir.»
-C'est gai.
-C'est pas si sombre, on peut rapprocher cette
formule du carpe diem.
-Une carpe par jour.
-Cueille le jour, qui incite à profiter de
la vie tant qu'on est en vie.
-L'idée du Jolly Roger, c'est donc de profiter
de la vie en faisant tout ce qu'on veut!
-Dans l'art, les natures mortes sont un autre
exemple très courant de memento mori.
Mais pourquoi faire de la piraterie? C'est
dangereux, on court le risque d'être tué
au combat, pendu, et la plupart des pirates
ne vivent pas très longtemps.
En plus ça ne rapporte pas tant que ça!
Alors pourquoi?
-As-tu déjà entendu parler du commerce triangulaire,
moussaillon? Des tas de navires, qui sillonnent
la mer chargés de diverses richesses, et
cela n'aiguise pas ton appétit?
-D'accord, vous voulez de l'or, des richesses,
mais au risque de faire un raccourci grossier...
Le vol, c'est mal.
Alors pourquoi?
-Tu connais Grotius?
-Il a écrit le traité Mare Liberium, en
1609, qui explique grosso modo que la mer
est à tout le monde...
-Alors elle est à nous aussi.
Et on y fait ce qu'on veut.
-Ouais...
Mais tu peux aussi être marin sans passer
par la case pirate.
-Ah oui, j'ai essayé ça! On travaille
toute la journée, faut obéir aux ordres,
on a à peine assez à manger...
J'ai essayé, les navires marchands, et j'ai
vite changé de camp.
Chez les pirates on a moins de contraintes,
moins de hiérarchie, le bonheur!
-Ooooh, elle se plaint de ses conditions de
travail la petite pirate? Essaie le servage,
quelques jours, on en reparlera...
Vous connaissez sûrement d'autres termes
pour désigner les pirates des Caraïbes,
telles que boucanier, flibustier...
Eh bien il existe des nuances entre ces termes.
Le boucanier, d'abord, a un rôle bieeeen
spécifique puisqu'il s'agit de communautés,
basées à Saint-Domingue et sur l'Île de
la Tortue, qui chassent le cochon et le bœuf
sauvage et qui le fument.
La viande, hein.
Et ils pratiquent aussi le commerce de leurs
peaux.
-C'est tout?!
-Pour la plupart il s'agit de marins ou d'esclaves
en fuite, des populations pauvres, voire d'anciens
pirates qui ont décidé de prendre leur retraite.
Il s'agit d'une forme de commerce en marge,
qui repose en partie sur la contrebande, et
c'est pourquoi elle devient associée à la
piraterie.
En plus les boucaniers fréquentent les pirates,
puisqu'ils vivent dans les mêmes espaces.
Certains boucaniers embarquent même de temps
en temps pour faire un peu de piraterie, avant
de retourner chasser le cochon.
Leur aventure prend fin à la fin du XVIIe
siècle, où faute de gibiers ils sont forcés
de se reconvertir.
J'utilise le terme de pirate depuis tout à
l'heure, mais on n'a pas encore abordé les
flibustiers!
Le mot flibustier désigne spécifiquement
les pirates d'origine française, anglaise
ou hollandaise qui exercent la piraterie en
mer des Caraïbes aux XVIe et XVIIe siècles.
Leur nom vient du néerlandais vrijbuiter,
qui signifie «qui fait du butin librement»
soit en langage moderne «je fais ce que
je veux yolo».
Ce sont surtout les pirates installés sur
l'île de la Tortue, que j'ai déjà abordée
quand j'ai parlé des boucaniers.
Quand je disais que les boucaniers fréquentaient
des pirates, il s'agissait donc des flibustiers.
C'est le français Pierre Belain d'Esnambuc
qui prend possession de l'île au début du
XVIIe siècle au détriment des espagnols
qui l'occupaient.
Rejoints par des anglais et des hollandais,
les nouveaux habitants de l'île décident
de se lancer dans la flibuste.
Les gouverneurs successifs de l'île, qui
passe aux mains des espagnols, puis des anglais,
puis à nouveau des français, tolèrent toujours
l'activité des flibustiers.
L'un des gouverneurs français, Levasseur,
accorde même des autorisations aux flibustiers
pour qu'ils s'attaquent à des navires espagnols.
C'était pas la grande entente.
Les flibustiers sont donc à mi-chemin entre
le pirate et le corsaire, puisque leur activité
est tolérée.
-Et comme précisé dans la première vidéo,
un corsaire est un pirate autorisé par un
État à exercer.
Les villes de Port-Royal, en Jamaïque, et
de Nassau aux Bahamas sont également d'importants
repaires de flibustiers.
A Port-Royal on retrouve le pirate Henry Morgan,
tandis que Barbe Noire gouverne Nassau.
A partir des années 1680 les flibustiers
présents dans les Caraïbes sont chassés
par les français et les anglais, et ils se
dispersent donc vers les côtes africaines
pour certains, ou vers le Pacifique.
Flibustiers et boucaniers ont marqué l'Histoire
de ces îles durant un siècle, et se désignaient
sous le nom de «frères de la côte».
La piraterie se développe dans l'Océan Indien,
notamment autour de Madagascar, où elle est
alimentée par les flibustiers qui ont quitté
l'île de la Tortue.
En mer de Chine, la piraterie se développe
à la même époque sous l'ère Ming.
A cette période la Chine connaît un repli
sur elle-même, le contact avec les civilisations
étrangères est interdit et le commerce devient
le monopole de l’État.
-Tu m'étonne que ça ait entraîné de la
piraterie!
En mer de Chine, la piraterie est le fait
de plusieurs personnages:
Les Tanka, d'abord, sont des paysans riches
de la région de Canton.
La piraterie est aussi le fait de japonais,
qu'on appelle les wako et qui sont employés
par certaines familles marchandes de Canton.
La piraterie en mer de Chine diminue à partir
du milieu du XVIe siècle: l'empereur améliore
la défense des villes et assouplit sa politique
commerciale.
Comme ça, plus besoin de pirates!
Cependant la chute de la dynastie Ming entraîne
à partir de 1644 une résurgence de la piraterie,
mais pas de panique: les nouveaux dirigeants
y mettent fin avant la fin du XVIIe siècle.
Cela n'empêche pas la piraterie de ressurgir
régulièrement, à la fin du XVIIIe siècle,
et de nouveau a milieu du XIXe siècle.
Alors bien sûr, tout ça fait un peu rêver.
La culture populaire nous vante des pirates
cools, sans foi ni loi, libres.
Pour ceux qui soupirent de nostalgie en pensant
aux époques révolues et qui se demandent
«à quelle époque passée j'aurais aimé
vivre?», l'âge d'or de la piraterie
représente un sacré potentiel de badasserie
mis en valeur par la littérature, le cinéma,
les jeux vidéos ou les séries.
-Merci de pas nous oublier, ça me va droit
au cœur.
Pourtant, la piraterie existe encore.
Elle est même en augmentation, si on en croit
ce graphique du Bureau Maritime International.
Comme depuis l'Antiquité, elle se concentre
dans les lieux de circulation les plus importants:
les détroits et canaux, le long des côtes.
On la retrouve surtout en mer des Caraïbes,
où elle est facilitée par ses nombreuses
petits îles; au débouché du Canal de
Suez, dans le golfe d'Aden, du fait des pirates
somaliens; et enfin dans toute l'Asie du
Sud-Est et surtout au niveau du détroit de
Malacca, qui est l'un des détroits les plus
fréquentés au monde.
Si on compare la piraterie à une carte des
principales routes maritimes...
Ça se suit!
Les attaques sont menées contre des petits
pétroliers ou méthaniers, principalement,
afin de s'approprier leur cargaison.
Au large de la Somalie, les pirates visent
aussi les bateaux de croisière afin de rançonner
les touristes souvent fortunés qui s'y trouvent.
C'est le cas du Ponant, en 2008, un voilier
de croisière dans lequel les touristes ont
été gardés huit jours en otage et libérés
contre une rançon.
Une partie des pirates a été ensuite arrêtée
en Somalie.
Les pirates viennent de pays pauvres et se
tournent vers la piraterie parce que l'économie
de leur pays ne leur permet pas de vivre autrement.
De ce fait, aussi, les pays concernés par
la piraterie ne sont pas en mesure d'intervenir
eux-mêmes pour lutter contre ce phénomène.
Ils ne sont pas assez équipés, et n'ont
pas les moyens de former et d'entretenir une
flotte destinée à la surveillance de leurs
eaux.
La lutte contre la piraterie est donc internationale:
elle est le fait du Bureau maritime international,
de l'Organisation maritime internationale
et d'Interpol.
Il existe aussi un observatoire régional
de la piraterie à Kuala Lumpur.
Des patrouilles de sécurité ont été autorisées
par le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU, en
Malaisie et en Somalie, et tendent à faire
diminuer les actes de piraterie ces dernières
années.
Je terminerait cependant en mentionnant l'intervention
des dirigeants africains au Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU, en 2009: ils déclaraient que
c'est une bonne chose d'aider à lutter contre
la piraterie, mais que cette lutte serait
encore plus efficace si on s'efforçait d'abord
de régler les problèmes de paix, de sécurité
et de crise humanitaire que connaissent ces
pays et qui sont à l'origine de la piraterie.
-Ben...
C'est vrai que...
-Tu veux qu'on parle de tes problèmes?
-ON M'A JAMAIS ENCOURAGÉEEE
-Ça va aller...
-Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode, on se
retrouve
la prochaine fois pour du Chroniques de Prof
ou du Créatrices du Tube, je ne sais pas
encore...
En attendant merci et à bientôt !